how do i come up with an idea for a
startup
i get asked this every week of my life
how do i come up with a great idea for a
startup and
there are many different theories about
this some people believe
you should really do a bunch of user
interviews and study customers and then
back into an idea other people think you
need to have the magical moment where
you couldn't get a cab at the web
conference and garrett camp says to
travis you know there should be an app
for this for ordering a cab and all of a
sudden you get one or
sometimes it happens through a pivot you
start with one idea and then you see
some need in another area and your first
idea is not working and you learn
something
during that first idea and it informs
the pivot and the next idea you come up
with
so
you don't have to come out with
something out of thin air i wrote a blog
post back in 2015 is inventing is
inventing something new necessary for
startups
and it turns out most of the great
startups of our time were evolutionary
not revolutionary
so let's look at a couple of them now
google there were a dozen search engines
before larry page and sergey brin came
up with the idea for google and page
rank where
the top couple of websites and who they
link to would inform
how
valid or important different websites
were and
long before that algorithm
got going people were doing full text
indexes and people were gaming the
system and search results were let's be
honest garbage and there was lycos and
magellan and
you know yahoo directory there were tons
of different ways
to search for stuff but google wound up
getting 90 percent of market share
across the board
in search on a global basis with the
exception of maybe four different uh
places in the world
china
south korea
russia
small number of places taiwan uh i think
also um
[Music]
japan with yahoo so there are a very
small number of places that actually uh
beat google but they were not the first
to do a search engine obviously they
just built something that was 10 times
better than anything that had come
before it and
they had an incredible business model
which was you whatever you typed in a
search box they created an auction for
those so it really was
making a better mousetrap and then also
having a better model for selling the
mousetrap there was a business model
innovation combined with a product
innovation or just a dramatically better
product they look at facebook
well when facebook came out we had these
big debates because myspace and
friendster were incredible but
myspace and friendster kept crashing
and nobody had ever seen virality
in the marketplace before virality was a
new concept that a website would become
instantly
massively popular and every user who
joined would bring 2.5 users or 1.8
users and the thing would just grow like
a wildfire
and
databases and web tools and servers and
caching didn't exist to the way it does
today and certainly cloud computing
didn't exist so myspace and friendster
were constantly crashing under their own
weight and they were also
myspace wasn't designed very well so you
had facebook come along they basically
knocked off the idea
they had less features but more
stability and all they did was focus on
growth so facebook
built a better mousetrap because it was
very simple it stayed up and running it
was as simple as that
and there was nothing original about
facebook in fact almost everything they
did they copied those ideas so it was
simply executed at a much higher level
and they brought an innovation to it
which was move fast break things in
other words it doesn't matter where the
chips fall let them fall where they may
we don't care
about people's privacy like other
services do we're going to allow you to
add people to groups we're going to
allow you
uh to we're going to upload your address
book we're going to do all these crazy
things that other people might feel um
it might be a little unethical or a
little too aggressive
facebook did not have
any
problem with aggressively pursuing
growth even if it meant that people's
privacy
was compromised in any way and that was
a big part of their success was that
they were marauding and they were the
fastest company to a trillion dollars
and to a certain extent we're sitting
here in their second decade and they're
kind of still doing it aren't they like
they're just like we're going to just
copy snapchat or clubhouse or
sub stack and review they'll just copy
anything and they'll copy it three or
four times until they get it right and
they don't care they don't feel bad
about stealing your idea nor do they
feel bad about people's privacy getting
compromised they just want to grow
apple they did not invent the mp3 player
they did not invent the smartphone they
did not invent the tablet nor did they
invent wireless headphones all those
products were in the market long before
apple entered those markets steve jobs
was just a complete visionary in terms
of product design and simplicity and
making things at the right time there's
always this famous story they brought in
the ipad before the iphone but the
large screen and the processing and the
battery just wasn't ready for that task
uh you know the touchscreen was like a
big new idea in fact people hated the
concept of a touchscreen remember your
blackberry you couldn't touch the screen
you had to use the keyboard
and he was like no you're going to use
this keyboard on your touch screen and
it was terrible at the start
but he knew
that he had this vision
that would make it so gorgeous so easy
to use that it would have mass market
appeal and that really was his gift now
you look at tesla they were not the
first battery power car in fact
everybody had given up but elon found a
really great idea we're gonna sell the
first hundred cars for 150k the
roadsters and i have number 16 in the
driveway not far from here and
what an amazing innovation we're going
to go after the highest end part of the
market first most people say well
shouldn't you go for
a very accessible car like a prius no
because these cars were
super expensive to build the first
battery packs were 30 or 40 grand from
what i read online and
they were you know really bespoke in the
beginning and then model s and then
model 3 and model y and the cyber truck
right just relentless innovation but
starting at the high end uber as well
started on the high end and then worked
their way down there was taxi magic and
a couple of other services before uber
uh and so those just a couple of
examples of companies that really
you know took ideas that maybe other
people gave up on like people gave up on
electric vehicles uh people gave up on
touch screens and tablets obviously
microsoft was very much involved in
tablets bill gates was all over tablet
computing and the ipad would just turned
out to be a better product
hey everybody i thought i would have
christina cassiopo on this weekend
startups to tell you about phantom fanta
of course has been sponsoring the pod
and had a great reaction and we're going
to talk today just a little bit about
what sock 2 compliance is and why it's
so important for sas products welcome to
the pod christina thank you so much for
having me how long does this typically
take
and what does it cost yeah so in the uh
you know prior world if you didn't use
software like vanta often companies
would take about a year on the project
to figure out what they needed to do get
everything in order work with the
auditor get the auditor what they needed
to get their report and they probably
spent 20 000 on the low end kind of can
go up to hundreds of thousands of
dollars depending on how large you are
you figured out a way at vanta to do
this
um quicker better and cheaper so what is
the secret and how can people
use the product yeah absolutely so
secret is sort of like a lot of things
you turn you turn a lot of this into
software so you uh write a standardized
set of checks that a company needs to do
you base them on good security
principles and then you just monitor and
alert all of those things so the company
gets a dashboard they always know where
they are they're not you know mucking
around in spreadsheets and the auditor
gets just really detailed data so they
can be sure that what the company says
they're doing is actually happening all
right fantastic well thanks so much for
coming on and telling the audience why
you should get your sock 2 when you
should get it and how you should do it
and you've been very nice to our
audience giving them a thousand dollars
off which is a really significant and
generous offer go to vanta.comtwist
twist to get a thousand dollars off your
sock too thanks christina appreciate it
thank you so much